sous la pression du coc vite 19 et de la
guerre le travail des enfants ne cessent
d'augmenter au yémen conséquence de la
crise sanitaire qui touche le monde
entier les aides humanitaires ont
diminué dans tout le pays
une situation qui force les familles
dépendantes pour la plupart des secours
à se tourner vers des mesures
désespérées
au début de l'été l'onu avait déjà
alarmé sur la situation humanitaire au
yémen
laissant des millions de personnes dans
un état vulnérable
les enfants sont certainement les plus
touchés par la guerre ou yémen en
général et particulièrement à taïz les
enfants qui ont survécu aux effets
directs de la guerre comme les tirs
isolés où les bombardements aveugles ne
survivront jamais à la souffrance du
travail dans la ville de taiz il n'est
pas rare de voir des enfants ont réparé
des voitures ou travailler dans la vente
de bouteilles d'eau alors que le chômage
ne cesse de croître les bombardements et
les destructions massives ont affecté de
nombreuses écoles et ont conduit de
nombreux enfants à être privés
d'éducation
j'ai été forcé de faire ce travail parce
que mon père est malade qu'il a mal au
dos et qu'il ne peut plus travailler et
que je dois travailler pour subvenir aux
besoins de ma famille j'ai eu la chance
de trouver ce travail je travaille pour
subvenir aux besoins de ma famille
cependant le salaire n'est pas suffisant
au début du mois d'août la convention de
l'organisation internationale du travail
et signé par la totalité de ses 187
états membres sur les pires formes de
travail des enfants
alors que les nations unies ont proclamé
l'année 2000 21 comme celle de
l'élimination du travail des enfants
l'organisation internationale du travail
craint que le coït 19 et ses
conséquences économiques
nan eu complètement les progrès de ces
dernières années